but he is with blue background just like
the thing to do nowadays I guess so this
video started out as a video about the
rumor that Christian Bale was going to
be in the Justice League movie then I
looked into it I guess that rumors
debunked now he's not going to be in the
Justice League movies Batman then as I
was planning to do a video on the
subject my brains been wracked with my
opinion on a Justice League movie I
figure it's still worth doing a video
about since it's my general thoughts on
the subject of Justice League movie so
as the Avengers has made a Tilian
dollars a Justice League movie is going
to happen it's inevitable but I don't
envy DC in that venture at all because
they already have the Christopher Nolan
Batman but Batman's in the Justice
League movie so what do they do and the
initial reaction would be you will you
can't have Christian Bale in the Justice
League movie because his story's done
but maybe you can have Joseph
gordon-levitt right but it's still part
of the Christopher Nolan universe and I
don't think that works for a Justice
League movie the Christopher Nolan
Batman movies existed as a realistic
take on Batman Ra's al Ghul wasn't
immortal the Joker painted his face he
wasn't bleach dane didn't use venom
because that would be too unrealistic so
to have any element of that christopher
nolan world in the Justice League movie
I don't think would work because you
have supernatural things in the Justice
League movie and you need those
supernatural things in order for it to
be Justice League you can't go from Oh
Christopher Nolan realism to now we have
Martians and aliens and Kryptonians and
someone who lives in Atlantis and talks
to fish she can't really have all these
things integrate plus the fact if you do
have the Christopher Nolan universe
linked into the Justice League movie
that is now establishing that Superman
did exist in the Christopher Nolan
Batman movies so when Bane's alike
is a bomb I'm going to blow up Gotham
what was Superman doing super it was
just like not worth my time I'm having a
Wonder Woman up to the fortress of
solitude we're gonna hang out there for
half a year it's really inconvenient for
me I'm not comparing any of these
franchises or movies to Batman and Robin
but it is like the part in Batman and
Robin with crystal Donald's like I like
the card chicks dig the car and then
George Clooney I'm not gonna call him
Batman I'm in a column George Clooney
says this is why Superman works alone I
was always just like alright so you've
established that Superman does exist in
this movie he's not in the movie but he
is in the universe that the movie is in
so when freeze is freezing Gotham and a
bunch of plastic fake icicle props
what's he doing Superman just like again
not worth my time I finally convinced
Lois Lane to
in ways she didn't want to experiment
before it try come on
Margot Kidder Louis all right I guess
I'll make time so this is the tough
situation what do they do
Christopher Nolan is going to produce
his Justice League movie of course we
now live in a world where anything DC
and Warner Brothers is going to be
produced by Christopher Nolan doesn't
mean it's a part of his Batman universe
it's just it's going to happen that way
integrating the Christopher Nolan
universe into the Justice League movie
would be like a really average normal
nerdy dude dating or marrying a
Victoria's Secret model I want to see it
happen but in reality if they don't have
common ground it's not realistically
gonna work out that's the way I see it
anyway and Man of Steel's coming out
it's not even out yet someone doing a
Justice League movie do you have that
Superman in the Justice League movie or
do you reboot Superman before that new
franchise even gets off the ground you
could squeeze Henry Cavill and Zack
Snyder Superman into it by having
something in the end credits that does
tie in to the Justice League really
that's what Iron Man did nothing in the
first Iron Man movie really alluded to
the Avengers until after the credits DC
and the whole Justice League franchise
is in the classic situation where their
opponent Marvel in this case struck hard
struck fast and did it right it totally
killed it with the Avengers they had all
the Avengers characters have their own
movies which all led up to the Avengers
with the Green Lantern they could reboot
that I imagine they're going to reboot
that Green Lantern's going to be like
the Hulk
eglee did the Holika like it very soon
after that the Hulk was rebooted now it
was part of the Avengers so again these
are my thoughts on the subject Christian
Bale I guess is not going to be in the
Justice League movie as Batman but that
sparked my brain into thinking about a
Justice League movie and I was like how
are they going to do that what are they
gonna do why is it so difficult to make
a Justice League movie so these are some
of my thoughts on the subject
two words that's actually one word
Batman integrate the Nolan Batman reboot
the franchise or just have Batman in the
Justice League movie without a movie
leading up to it in which case he
doesn't have any backstory or character
development neither of those situations
is ideal but that's just what they have
to work with alright so a Justice League
movie what are your thoughts on it's not
really in the spotlight right now and I
guess we'll have to see how Menace steel
goes but I'm still curious as to what
you guys think about it what do you
think they should do how do you think
they should do it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you